hey everybody it's Mike from OTS here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for today's video where
I'm going to be talking about you know
different markets and you know what's a
good Market to trade if you're new to
orderflow okay because you know I get
this question quite often again it's
something
that is important to understand right
because you know a lot of Traders come
to the market and right away you know
they just want to start trading NASDAQ
or or e- minis when it's probably not
the best most prudent idea for them to
do but before I jump in you know I can't
stress enough be sure to subscribe to
this channel so that uh you know when I
do post up new videos you can get
notified and if you find today's video
helpful be sure to hit that like button
for me you know leave some comments
below and I love hearing your feedback
you know hopefully this weekend I get
some chance to go through the questions
and make some videos based off of your
comments right I I do love going through
them and and answering your questions
when I have the time so your sport
really does go a long way in helping me
create more awesome content just like
this right so let's jump into today's
topic okay what's a good Market to trade
with orderflow okay
because reason why I think this is an
important topic is not everybody has the
same mindset right when it comes to
trading some people are very risk averse
While others are willing to take shots
okay you know in American football no
there's that saying no risk it no
biscuit right you're not going to get
rewarded unless you take risks but at
the same time you know we're trading
with money and if you are making
mistakes or trading poorly you are
losing money it's money out of your
pocket right money that you can do
things with go on vacation buy things
with buy clothes buy food whatever um
nobody likes to lose right and so that's
why picking the right Market or at least
exposing yourself to different markets
to see which one suits your personality
is important to understand right because
again it's one thing you know you you go
on Facebook you you see these groups out
there for you know
these funded Trader programs oh yeah I
just made $3,000 today trading enq then
everyone think oh I got to trade NQ well
no you trade what suits you okay because
first of all you don't know how the
other person is even Trading
and you know I talk a lot about e- minis
I think e- minis is a good market for
Traders to get introduced to reading the
order flow with but at the same time for
beginning Traders it might be too much
right it might be overload because
you're seeing you know the price move
around very quickly um heaven forbid you
know you're going to just jump right in
and start trading NQ if you you've never
looked at order flow before right
because now
right the difference between say es and
NQ this is M andq this is a 30 second
chart you you're getting very big bars
right and it's going to be difficult for
a lot of traders to understand really
what's taking place when a bar goes from
855 and a quarter all the way down to 37
and almost almost a 20 point move in 30
seconds and that happens over and over
and over right at least in the e- minis
you know moves are more muted compared
to a market like NQ now what are some of
the markets that I would suggest for
Traders that are new to trading with
order flow that do um have nice
movements that does have order flow that
is um easy to you know understand in the
beginning well treasuries right interest
rates 10 years is a great market for
Traders new to trading now this is a one
minute chart okay but the problem is
since it's a slower moving Market
trading a one minute chart on 10 years
isn't going to be very effective it's
going to be hard because now all you're
doing is you're just trading basically
the bid and the offer right and that's
not going to really give you much to go
off of so what I would suggest is
putting the
chart into a more readable format which
would be in my opinion I've used this
chart for over a decade is a range-based
chart I like to use on treasuries I like
to use a four range chart okay now maybe
you want to use a 5 minute chart but
really what you want to have is a chart
that helps you see in the orderflow what
you're trying to analyze which is volume
at
price and you need movement as well so
if you're on a one minute chart and it
just looks like it's flatlining you're
not going to be able to make any decent
trading decisions at least in my opinion
okay so then once you have your
footprint chart you know in a format
that you like like a market you know
again one of the reasons why I suggest
10 years I mean nowadays you know over
the last couple years with interest
rates being um you know higher than when
they're at 0% now you're getting a lot
of decent price movements actually in
the 10 years because in the past you
know a decade ago the movements used to
be very small for the day but you have a
lot of volume you can see these bars you
know they're trading 60,000 contracts
8,000 26,000 20,000 37,000 so if you
have to get out the liquidity is there
okay and that's important to understand
you know having liquidity that is there
so that if you're wrong and you need to
get out quickly there's a bid or there's
an offer
right so once you have your chart you
again this is a uh four range chart you
know maybe you want to use a volume
based chart I don't know what You' want
to use here maybe you want to use a
10,000 volume based chart right again it
it's up to you to decide what you want
but it's got to at least have some
activity taking place in the bar that
you can analyze right as opposed to um
you know a one minute chart right you
can see here this is a one minute
chart where it's just basically trading
one or two prices in a bar right there's
not much movement to go off of right
that's why I like to use a four range
chart right because now bars are being
formed on price movements okay so then
you got to decide okay what what do I
want to focus on right and because for
example right my orderflows Trader
software we got a lot of tools here okay
got buying and selling Tales Divergence
exhaustion prints imbalance
reversals um Market sweeps Market
weakness sequencing ratios Etc right and
it's not a case of well I'm just going
to put everything up on my chart no
right if you were to look at ninja
Trader at itself right and you see in
here under all these indicators there's
hundreds of these I don't even know what
a lot of these things are honestly you
know and I've been in the market since
the early 1990s you know now the tricks
tsf I don't know what the heck these
things are called I mean you know maybe
I got left behind or something but you
know there's a lot of these indicators I
don't know what they mean and the same
thing when you're starting out with the
orderflows trader you don't just go
throw everything up all at once right
you you want to use the pieces that's
going to help you understand what's
taking place in the market like a Swiss
army knife right Swiss Army knife's got
all these tools it's got Phillips head
screwdriver flathead screwdriver cork
screw um bottle opener all these things
you're not going to use them all at once
okay so the orderflows trader is a tool
to help you understand the orderflow so
what you want to start looking at is
certain things right and I always
recommend people start with with um you
know maybe start first with the
Prominent Point of controls okay now
it's a four range chart so I suggest
Prominent Point of control level
one and you know level two okay you just
put it up on your charts and you can see
these areas where there's support or
resistance right resistance some support
coming in okay um and then you start of
go from there you start
adding things to your chart that is
going to help you understand what it is
you're looking at okay maybe you want to
add exhaustion prints okay what's an
exhaustion print an exhaustion
print right here is volume at the edge
of bars that's indicates when the last
buyer has bought or the last seller has
sold okay and you could set you sort of
your volume limits right I like to use
nine you know basic you can use 10 but I
like to keep it in single digits um you
can use whatever volume you want right
in a market like uh 10 years that trade
a lot of volume you could use a bigger
number right maybe you want to use you
know 50 or something but you know just
keep it at nine go from there we'll keep
it until tested and we're going to look
for these areas where there's an
exhaustion print taking place okay I can
see an exhaustion print took place here
one here one here open up this chart a
little bit
more okay sometimes you know Ninja
Trader like H the software you know it
won't expand anymore what it's problem
is the data Series right it's maxed out
candle bar withd you just got to change
it to a different number other than 100
100 is the max you could go but if you
just change it to 10 right then you
could obviously expand it up so okay now
I see oh I got exhaustion here I've got
exhaustion here I've got exhaustion here
right and you sort of see these things
you know at a turning point here right
sell off come come up just a little bit
and then sell off some
more you know maybe you want to see bars
that
have you know multiple imbalances okay
so remember this is a 4 range chart it's
not you know it's not a chart like M
andq where you're trading such big
ranges okay it's a four range chart So
you you're only trading five price
levels so you know if you're looking at
say stacked imbalances we'll start with
stacked
imbalances um
where are we here stacked imbalance are
getting three stacked imbalances on a
chart where there's only five price
levels is going to be a stretch I mean
you might get it um there's there's one
over here actually but you know
on shorter bar charts like a four range
chart or three range chart I'm not going
to use three I I would use two
okay set it to
two excuse me some
water so what do I see
okay well I know this green line is my
high of the day okay I got a buy and
balance up here but I'm up already up
here near the high I'd rather have a
reason to sell I got two selling
imbalances here two selling IM balances
here three here two here okay I got two
buying imbalances here then here I
obviously got my exhaustion print then
another two selling imbalances
okay so you know really you so you just
sort of go through that process seeing
which
things matter in the market that you're
training okay again and then you know
people ask well what if you I was I
don't want to trade 10 years know I want
to trade Euro currency okay well what
type of chart you're going to use if
you're going to use a a four range
chart could you could probably get away
with a 4 range chart in in eurocurrency
probably going to move fast at times but
you know I'd be looking at the same
things but this Market trades thinner
okay so if I was going to use something
like exhaustion prints maybe instead of
nine I would set it to a lower number
right because the volume is a lot less
right in the 10 years you're seeing bars
trade 10,000 20,000 and more but here on
the euro currency on a on a 4 range
chart I'm just seeing you know several
hundred so maybe instead of nine I just
drop it down to three could even have it
at one if I wanted
to okay but this is at three so I see
exhaustion print exhaustion print
exhaustion print okay selling IM
balances what do I got I got two selling
IM balances here I got Prominent Point
of control here here here here so you
can just see in here just from this
swing high right here in the middle at
1133 to where we are right
now you see any bullish activity not
really and here you got bullish P Point
control but that's it everything else is
bearish okay you know even down here
right we come down into the swing low
bullish prent Point control exhaustion
print and we start working our way back
up so again you know there's other
markets other than you know e- minis or
mnq right that that you can trade and
especially if you're new to order flow
choose one of these other markets to get
started with don't just jump right into
the fire and think I'm going to get it
right away when you've never used
orderflow
before right use look take a look at
another market and again you can use you
know whatever setup whatever type of
chart you like but in my opinion you
need to have some price activity in a
bar right if it's just like I showed you
earlier in the 10 years where it's just
trading the bid and the offer that's not
going to be ideal right you want
something that's going to give you some
price movement so you could so you could
see volume getting distributed in a CU
that's what order flow is about it's
about understanding the volume that's
trading in a bar okay so that wraps up
this video on you know different markets
I hope you found it helpful and you know
can help expand your understanding of
order flow better so let me know what
you like to discuss next by leaving a
comment down below so again if you
enjoyed this video and you haven't
already be sure to subscribe to the
channel and I'll catch you guys on the
next video
bye-bye